you left the boys the season 18 now is
considered to be the lowest rated opener
today the show went down 16 percent and
I want an honest answer I don't want any
horseshit all right I know where you're
going with this arctic area isn't there
some joy didn't you look at that number
and go okay okay well you might like
this answer but I had no [ __ ] idea
about any numbers about anything
like ireally anyone gee how is the The
Voice doing without me no I mean on a on
a level of like checking in with people
no hey like how's it going I miss you
guys you missed me [ __ ] you you know
like Carson and Blake all guys just like
checking in yeah not but not saying what
are the numbers are there worse yeah do
you check in with Gwen Stefani's
boyfriend that guy the country guy I
often fake like kind of like we all
group based on everyone so I do I really
like that guy I love and I love Gwen I
have a dog what Gwen is the greatest I
love them both and Blake look man that
guy he and I went on this fucked-up
journey that just two people never go
through with each other
the whole meteoric rise of that show was
so crazy to go through an experience and
we became friends during the process so
would you see him in general if if this
whole coronavirus thing wasn't going on
would you guys like kind of hang or it's
not that kind of thing I haven't seen
him in so long I'm sure obviously at
some point we will hang out and stuff
like that was obviously we hung out
every day for eight years so we're good
you saw him so much now but isn't there
an ego kind of boost in knowing the show
is not doing as well that no matter what
that you had that kind of impact I mean
come on
um no look secretly does everybody
harbor that desire like deep down of
course on some level however no I I
don't wish failure for a show that
doesn't have me on it I wish a show
success and by the way I
we also believe that the biggest reason
for the drop off on the voice is
definitely not me and it's the fact that
people watch TV less more and more I
think people just don't walk people
don't [ __ ] with TV like nearly as much
as they did when the voice starting very
gracious
you're being very gracious and not like
but like I'm not like us I'm not I'm a
competitive person like you won't find
many people as competitive as I am but I
am definitely not spiteful and I don't
wish yeah I don't think that failure
doesn't make me feel better really like
so I'm not like wishing that the voice
failed